people's generosity
in um across the country with regard to
people in portland us seems to be being
used to help out criminals
pray tell what might you be talking
about pray tell um
let's see uh the before we show before
we show the screen
uh funds that were created to pay bail
for people who were arrested while
engaging in vandalism or assault or
whatnot during the protests and
especially during
the riots in portland have been wait for
it
abused by those receiving the bail money
who would have thunk
color me [ __ ] shots color are you
[ __ ] shocked all right
so here just let's show the the tweet
before you start talking about it
uh from defense fund pdx some folks
think that bail funds can sustain
themselves because most bail eventually
gets refunded
in portland bail paid is returned to the
person arrested not the person that paid
the bail
we have paid over a hundred thousand
dollars in bail since may
we've only had a few folks return their
bill to us if you've had your bail
refunded please consider sending it back
to us if we paid it
you can return it via any of the methods
found in the link in our profile
if you want to mail a check dm for our
mailing address
gee shocked people who are arrested
for criminal behavior and get their bail
paid for them
from the generosity of well-meaning
liberals i would think mostly um
but there's no expectation tied to it at
the point that they actually show up for
what would it be their arraignment
um is it that is that when you get your
bail back
at whatever point in the process you
show up and you get your bail back they
get their bail back
it's not theirs but they take it and
they keep it
because of course they do yes so i
should tell you
at one point during the portion of
these riots that was attacking the uh
the courthouse downtown yeah um i
went down there spiking around and i saw
two people who were part of this bail
fund standing next to a sign about
donating to it and utilizing it and all
of this and i was shocked because
a the whole idea of a bail fund
certainly intervenes in the incentive
structures surrounding
these riots in a way that immediately it
was obvious like oh
what you're doing is you're dropping the
cost of rioting if you're
arrested during a riot i mean a the
state
abuses these penalties so one of the
things
let's leave rioting out of it for a
moment if you are
protesting peacefully you can be
arrested
for all kinds of violations trespassing
uh
protesting without a permit all sorts of
stuff yes and
it's a nightmare for people that it
happens to and
you know basically we had friends up in
olympia to whom this happened oh yeah
and there's a whole set of undeclared
penalties that come in the form of
bureaucracy that surrounds
you getting your due process right so
it's an actual actual nightmare and in
fact the cops
when they're going to arrest people at a
protest will often give them a choice
right they will say do you want to be
arrested and the basic point is if you
don't want to be arrested then you have
to do what we say and if you do want to
be arrested
then don't do what we say and we're
about to arrest you and then those
penalties will kick in and so anyway
it's a sort of
unspoken rule under normal protesting
but
in this case you've got people who are
rioting
you've got other people who are
signaling their virtue the riots are
ostensibly about
challenging racial inequity right
they're not but they say they are
you've got people who want to advertise
that they are in favor of racial equity
who are signaling this by donating to
this
fund to bail out these people who are
really in you know
in this portrayal uh uh misbehaving you
know it's civil disobedience
right um and by the latter day the rose
by lowering the penalty here you are
increasing
the uh incentive to continue right
now if this if these were really
peaceful protests and they were really
about
injustice that would be one thing but in
the context where
they are um actually attacking
courthouses and trying to pick a fight
with the cops and demonizing people and
threatening to kill them and all of
those things
it's preposterous to lower those costs
but what it turns out is that it's even
worse than i thought by a lot
because what's really happening is that
those who are donating
to reduce the cost of being arrested
are in effect paying people to engage
in those behaviors that get you arrested
so
what you have is people behaving in a
destructive
and violent way whose bail is then being
paid
they are freed and uh when they get the
money back
it comes to them so it is a payment
scheme
for those who are behaving in in these
in these ways and
and what a perfect tell for whether or
not these people actually uh
believe in the values that they espouse
most of
most of these uh these people will tell
you that there's something akin to
socialists
yeah um or you know or farther farther
left than that
right and um the the honorable the
important the valuable part of socialism
is returning that which belongs to
the community to the community right is
if you have a fund
that is a pool that is designed to help
people like you and you have been helped
in the past
you keep that pool alive by returning it
to the pool when you are done
this is you know this this is human
decency 101 but it's certainly important
um if you espouse any kind of
collectivist
uh thinking and anyone's failure to pay
back that
reveals them as exactly the opposite
yeah individualistic
um
yeah it's bad faith um and at some level
this is
subsidized anarchism and when you ask
yourself why it is that portland
has ongoing uh destruction of property
and violence
you know uh then this is part of your
answer is that
when you apply these principles locally
in this ham-fisted way what you do is
you end up paying people to riot
which is an absurd thing to pay people
for right it's uh
it's the most absurd jobs program
conceivable
[Music]